GUTFELD.
THIS IS THE "THE FIVE."
♪ THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSING TO
BACK DOWN WITH HIS BORDER
BATTLE TO BUILD THE WALL
TRUMP ISSUING THE FIRST VETO
OF HIS PRESIDENCY TO
OVERRULE A RESOLUTION THAT
BLOCKS HIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY DECLARATION AT THE
BORDER.
>> THE PROTECTION OF THE
NATION IS MY HIGHEST DUTY.
YESTERDAY CONGRESS PASSED A
DANGEROUS RESOLUTION THAT IF
PUT INTO LAW WOULD PUT
COUNTLESS AMERICANS IN
DANGER, VERY GRAVE DANGER.
IT IS DEFINITELY A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
RARELY HAVE WE HAD SUCH A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY
THEREFORE, TO DEFEND THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF ALL
AMERICANS, I WILL BE SIGNING
AND ISSUING A FORMAL VETO OF
THIS RECKLESS RESOLUTION
CONGRESS' VOTE TO DENY THE
CRISIS ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS A VOTE AGAINST
REALITY, IT'S AGAINST
REALITY.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS CRISIS.
PEOPLE HATE THE WORD
INVASION, BUT THAT'S WHAT IT
IS.
IT IS AN INVASION OF DRUGS
AND CRIMINALS AND PEOPLE.
CONGRESS HAS THE FREEDOM TO
PASS THIS RESOLUTION, AND I
HAVE THE DUTY TO VETO IT AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO VETO IT.
>> Jesse: SO MR. GUTFELD I
WATCHED THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE IN FULL AND I
THINK HE STOLE ONE OF HIS
LINES.
>> Greg: WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> Jesse: HE SAID THEY WERE
BORDER DENIERS AND REALITY
DENIERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK HE IS WATCHING
"THE FIVE."
>> Greg: MAYBE, I DON'T
THINK HE WATCHES MUCH FOX
THOUGH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK AT AN ERA GROWING
UP 90'S GRUNGE, 80'S ACID
WASH.
THIS YEAR IS GOING TO
THIS EEAR IS GOING TO
THIS ERAR IS GOING TO
THIS ERA IIS GOING TO
THIS ERA ISS GOING TO
THIS ERA IS GGOING TO
THIS ERA IS GOIING TO
THIS ERA IS GOINGG TO
THIS ERA IS GOING TTO
THIS ERA IS GOING TOO
THIS ERA IS GOING TO BE THE
WALL.
EVERY DAY WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE WALL.
IT'S HIS BIGGER PICTURE
WHICH IS SAFE AT HOME.
AN APPRECIATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO YOU HAVE A
LOT OF THE POLICE THERE.
YOU HAVE TRYING TO ERADICATE
THE TERROR THREAT AND
MILITARY BUILDUP.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE PART
OF ONE VISION.
HE TENDS TO SEE IT AS THAT.
AND OTHER PEOPLE SEE IT AS
FEAR MONGERING BECAUSE THAT
KIND OF BELIEF CAN BE SEEN
AS FEAR MONGERING.
YOU WANT A STRONG MILITARY.
YOU WANT A WALL.
YOU WANT LAW ENFORCEMENT OH
MY GOD YOU ARE SCARING
PEOPLE.
SO, UNFORTUNATELY SOMETHING
THAT HE BELIEVES IN CAN BE
RECAST AS SOMETHING WRONG.
THEY BROUGHT UP A FACT IN
THERE THAT MADE THEE THINK
ABOUT THE OTHER HALF OF THIS
STORY.
THE NUMBER ONE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR PEOPLE UNDER 50
DRUG OVERDOSE.
ONE OF THE OFFICERS SAID
THAT THERE I WAS THINKING
THE FAULT ISN'T IN THE
DEALERS ALONE.
YOU KNOW, THE DRUGS KEEP
COMING BECAUSE WE KEEP
USING.
AND I THINK THERE IS --
THERE IS A REFUSAL TO ADMIT
THAT OFTEN THE DRUG WAR
DOESN'T MAKE THINGS ANY
BETTER.
WE ARE SEEING THIS WITH THE
OPIOID MESS WHERE WE ARE
TRYING TO REDUCE -- WE ARE
REDUCING THE LEGAL WAYS TO
GET OPIOIDS AND THAT ENDS UP
IN OVERDOSES ON FENTANYL
WHICH ONE OF THE GENTLEMEN
SPOKE ABOUT HIS SON DYING ON
FENTANYL.
WE STILL HAVEN'T ADDRESSED
MAYBE THE UNDERPINNINGS OF
THIS STORY WHICH SOUR DESIRE
FOR BOLIVIAN.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE LIKE TO GET
I DON'T
ZODON'T
ZONKN'T
ZONKEDT
ZONKED OUT OF THEIR MINDS.
>> Greg: GREAT SUMMARY.
HAVE
.AVE
>>VE
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE DONE IT
AND I'M SURE JUAN HAS DONE
IT.
SPEAKING OF ZONKED, NANCY
PELOSI SAYS SHE IS GOING TO
HOLD A VOTE TO OVERTURN THIS
VETO BUT SHE NEEDS, I GUESS,
TWO THIRDS OF THE SENATE TO
UPHOLD THE OVERRIDE AND
THAT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE
MATHEMATICALLY.
>> Juan: NOT AT THE MOMENT.
BUT WHAT WE SAW WAS THE
TREMENDOUS NUMBER, I THINK
IT WAS 13 REPUBLICANS WHO
VOTED WITH THE DEMOCRATS IN
THE SENATE.
AND SO WHAT YOU ARE GETTING
THERE IS NOT VETO-PROOF
MAJORITY BUT YOU ARE GETTING
IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> Juan: WHAT HAVE YOU GOT
TO UNDERSTAND HERE IS THAT
YOU HAVE ESSENTIALLY A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
>> Jesse: JUAN?
>> Juan: REMEMBER, I'M
ZONKED OUT.
>> Lisa: YEAH, YOU ARE.
>> Juan: IN TRUMP WORLD I'M
ZONKED OUT.
>> Juan: ALLOW ME TO SPEAK.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
>> Juan: 58 NATIONAL
SECURITY OFFICIALS SAYING
THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
DON'T DO IT.
HAVE YOU IN TERMS OF THE
POLLING IN THE COUNTRY, 64%
OPPOSE THE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
58% OPPOSE THE WALL.
THIS ISN'T CLOSE, FOLKS.
BUT FOR TRUMP IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRUMP AND TRUMP'S POLITICAL
PROMISES.
>> Jesse: I WILL HIT YOU
BACK WITH THAT LINE.
>> Juan: I'M SHOCKED.
I'M SURPRISED WE ARE HERE ON
DAY 30 OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, COVER YOUR HEAD.
>> Jesse: THOSE WERE MOSTLY
OBAMA PEOPLE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE ACTUAL
SHERIFFS IF YOU WATCH THE
PRESS CONFERENCE, THEY DON'T
SAY IT'S MANUFACTURED.
THEY SAY IT'S A HUGE CRISIS,
LISA.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY ALL
THOSE REPUBLICANS VOTED.
>> Jesse: THEY INVITED A LOT
OF THESE CONGRESS MEN AND
SENATORS TO COME DOWN AND
SEE IT THEMSELVES BEFORE
THEY CAST THEIR NEXT VOTE.
>> Lisa: JUAN, YOU ARE
ZONKED OUT, MY FRIEND, EVEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN 2014
TALKING ABOUT THE CRISIS WE
HAD ALONG THE BORDER.
HE DID SO IN THE ROSE
GARDEN.
HE TALKED ABOUT TRAFFICKERS
BRINGING UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS ACROSS THE BORDER.
CALLING ON CONGRESS TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE WE HAD A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THAT HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
REMAINS TODAY.
THERE HAS BEEN 260,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER.
90% SINCE OCTOBER.
90% INCREASE FROM LAST YEAR.
ICE IS GIVING PREGNANCY
TESTS TO YOUNG GIRLS OVER
THE AGE OF 10 BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF RAPES AND SEXUAL
ASSAULTS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCED ALONG THE
JOURNEY.
OF COURSE WE HAVE A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THE QUESTION IS IT A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THE WAY
TO SOLVE IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THE POINT BEING IS THAT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW
IS EVERYONE EXERCISING THEIR
AUTHORITY UNDER THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES ACT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BROAD
AUTHORITY TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY UNDER THE
ACT.
CONGRESS ALSO GAVE
THEMSELVES THE AUTHORITY TO
TRY TO RESCIND THAT NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO THEN VETO AND
THEN CONGRESS CAN TRY TO
FIND THE VOTES, TWO THIRDS
IN THE HOUSE AND SENATE TO
OVERRIDE IT.
SO ESSENTIALLY EVERYONE IS
EXERCISING THE AUTHORITIES
THAT THEY HAVE UNDER THE
ACT.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU JUST SAID
THOUGH.
IF THIS IS NOT THE CARAVAN.
THIS IS NOT LIKE SOMEONE
INVADING OUR COUNTRY, LISA.
>> Greg: YOU SOUGHT CARAVAN
FIRST OFF, JUAN.
YOU WERE THE FIRST PERSON.
>> Lisa: HOW IS IT NOT A
CRISIS?
>> Juan: THAT'S SO
DIFFERENT.
>> Greg: HOW IS IT?
>> Juan: TALK ABOUT INVASION
AND YOU SEND TROOPS.
>> Greg: PEOPLE DIE NO
MATTER WHAT YOU CALL IT.
PEOPLE DIE.
>> Juan: NEVER HAS ANY
NATIONAL EMERGENCY BEEN
DECLARED TO GET AROUND THE
FACT THAT CONGRESS WON'T
FUND.
THIS IS AN EXCEPTIONAL.
>> Jesse: WHY DID THEY WRITE
THE ACT THAT WAY, JUAN?
DID CONGRESS WRITE AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ACT?
>> Juan: NO.
THEY SAY IT'S NEVER BEEN
DONE IS ALL I'M SAYING THEY
WROTE IT.
>> Jesse: DAGEN, I DON'T SEE
HOW THIS PLAYS OUT IN ANY
OTHER WAY THAT IT GETS TIED
UP IN THE COURTS.
>> Dagen: IT WILL GET TIED
I THINK THERE WERE FOUR
ADDITIONAL STATES THAT
SIGNED ON TO THIS LAWSUIT
CHALLENGING THE EMERGENCY
ORDER BRINGING IT TO 20.
YOU COULD GET AN EMERGENCY
INJUNCTION THAT STOPS THIS.
IN ITS TRACKS FOR THE TIME
BEING.
BUT, LISTEN, JUAN DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE WITH THE REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BEING
HYPOCRITICAL UNLIKE THE
DEMOCRATS.
UNLIKE CHUCK SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI WHO BASICALLY
JUST SAT BACK AND LET
PRESIDENT OBAMA VIOLATE THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE LIST.
AS THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
EDITORIAL BOARD WROTE.
A BLANK CHECK ON RECESS
APPOINTMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
AND FINANCIAL REGULATIONS.
OBAMACARE SPENDING WITHOUT
APPROPRIATIONS, WORK PERMITS
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
MORE ALL REBUKED BY THE
COURT SYSTEM.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE.
>> Dagen: AT LEAST THE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT ARE
VOTING BASED ON THEIR
CONCERN THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WILL THEN TURN AROUND AND
ABUSE THE EMERGENCY POWER.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
IS HE SHOULDN'T BE DOING IT.
>> Dagen: WHERE WERE YOU
GUYS WHEN OBAMA WAS DOING
THIS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> Juan: NOBODY HAS EVER
INCLUDING OBAMA EVER SAID
I'M GOING AROUND THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Dagen: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
>> Lisa: WHAT DO YOU THINK
HAPPENED WITH DACA, JUAN?
>> Juan: THAT WAS NOT ABOUT
FUNDING?
>> Lisa: MASSIVE OVERREACH
WITH DACA.
>> Juan: NOT ABOUT FUNDING.
I'M JUST SAYING IT WASN'T
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION AND
FUNDS.
>> Lisa: YOU
>> Dagen: DO YOU KNOW WHY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT LEAST SO
FAR DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
ANNOYED WITH THESE
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE HE ISN'T
CALLING THEM NAME ON TWITTER
YET MAYBE MITT ROMNEY
DESERVES THAT STUPID OP-ED
IN BLOWING OUT THE CANDLES?
>> Jesse: IF I WANTED TO
PRESSURE HIM I WOULD HAVE
BROUGHT THE PRESSURE.
I DIDN'T NEED IT BECAUSE WE
HAD THE VOTES.
BUT IF THEY WANT TO SEE
PRESSURE, THEY WILL KNOW
WHAT PRESSURE IS.
>> Greg: THE ONLY REASON WHY
WE ARE HERE IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CAN'T ADMIT THAT
THEY WANT WHAT TRUMP WANTS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T ADMIT
THAT THEY AGREE WITH HIM.
WE ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME THING.
WE WANT AN ENFORCED BORDER
THEY CAN'T ADMIT IT BECAUSE
THAT MEANS TRUMP IS RIGHT.
THAT'S ALL THIS IS ABOUT.
PETTY POLITICAL STEAM SPORT.
>> Juan: I'M GLAD YOU SAID
THAT DEMOCRATS DO WANT IT.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME WHAT
YOU HEAR FROM REPUBLICANS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T.
YOU ARE RIGHT, GREG.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Juan: WE HAVE A HISTORY
OF DEMOCRATS FUNDING THIS
KIND OF STUFF.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT SURE THE
DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT.
>> Juan: HIM AND HIS
POLITICAL PROMISE.
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS MADE IT
ABOUT HIM.
IS HE A LARGE CHARACTER,
JUAN.
IT'S HARD NOT TO.
>> Juan: FULFILLING A
CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE MADE IT
ABOUT HIM.
THEY CAN'T GIVE IT TO HIM.
>> Juan: REPUBLICANS IN THE